in a previous video we introduced a
flowchart that helps us think about what
strategies to use when trying to
determine a limit of a function as it
approaches a point what we're going to
do in this video is now try to apply
that in several example exercises so the
first question they say based on the
process in the flowchart let's try to
find the limit as X approaches 3 of f of
X 4 f of X is equal to this business
what are the steps that we should go
through and they have these various
steps even you might say well what is a
and B and C DNA well if you go back to
the original flowchart you see this is a
this is B this is C this is B etc etc so
let's let's just first try to substitute
see if we can get a value for f of 3 if
f of 3 works then we are essentially
done because this is not some strange
exotic function it seems like it's
continuous if function around x equals 3
if f of 3 exists so let's try it out so
let me so i'm going to have f of 3 is
equal to the square root of let's see
6-5 2 times 3 minus 5 minus 1 over 3
minus 3 so in the numerator here we get
0 because this is 1 minus 1 so this is
going to be equal to 0 over 0 so the
first thing that happens is we fall into
the in that we tried to evaluate it we
fell into indeterminate form so the
first step is going to be see now the
next thing that I would do because we
have a radical expression here is to see
if I can take a conjugate so it's going
to likely be we're definitely gonna have
C first then we're going to try e and
frankly that's the only choice that has
that but let's actually see if that
actually works ceb so let me multiply
this expression x a conjugate so square
root of two x
minus 5 minus 1 over X minus 3 times
square root of two X minus 5 plus 1 is
the conjugate here over square root of
two X minus 5 plus 1 and this is going
to be equal to see this numerator square
root of two X minus 5 squared it's going
to be 2x minus 5 and then you're going
to have negative you have a minus 1
squared which is going to be minus 1 all
of that over X minus 3 times square root
of two X minus 5 plus 1 and see let's
see this stuff up here this is you can
rewrite as 2x minus 6 2 X minus 6 which
is the same thing as 2 times X minus 3
and so those cancel out nicely and so
let's see this is going to be equal to 2
over square root of two X minus 5 plus 1
now let's try to evaluate this when x
equals 3 well if we do that we're going
to get to / so this is going to be 6-5
the square root which is one plus one so
it's 2 over 2 which is equal to one so
then we were able to evaluate it and we
actually got a value so we feel pretty
good that we're done so we went from we
went from finding indeterminate form
taking the conjugate and then being able
to evaluate it let me just show that
right over here when we immediately try
to evaluate it we got indeterminate form
we recognize that it was a radical that
it was a rational expression with a
radical on top and sir say let's
multiply by the conjugate we did that
and then after we were able to simplify
it with the conjugate we tried to
evaluate it again and we were able to
get a real number so we feel pretty good
that that is going to be the limit